همم لا اعرف اذا حدا اسمائهم قبلي شيوخ
الشهوه همم الذين يخرجون بكما تفضلت حتى
بالمظهر الخارجي والشكل حقيقيه الذقن
ويرتدون ال ال ال البدلات الانيقه والفخبه
وربطات العنق الفخمه كذلك ويتحدثون بامور
الدين بحديث بسيط اعتقد هذا ياخذنا لقول
او مقوله قال همم الدكتور محمد عرقون
بخصوص المخيال العاطفي الجبار الذي يحرك
المتلقي الاسلامي او الراي العام الاسلامي
اليوم هذا المقال العاطف الجبار اعتقد لا
اقول انه اصبح واقعيا الى درجه كبيره جدا
لكن العلم اليوم ياخذ مداه اكبر همم من
الخرافات والخزعبلات التي يتم دي في بيها
وضحك على الدخول
لاقناع الراي العام باي اساليب سواء
المتشدد والمتطرف همم او هذا شيخ الشوق
المدن همم الذي باسانيد